[Musique]
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui s'en vient
mr.  l'esprit a enfreint les règles,
j'espère que vous comprenez les répercussions
s'il survit à John lorsque le
propriétaire de la communauté X est maintenant,
vous ne devriez pas être ici, je suppose que c'est bon
de vous voir - j'ai besoin de votre aide après cela,
nous sommes moins que même il n'y a pas d'échappatoire
pour vous le  table haute veut ta vie
[Musique
] pourrais-tu aider à préparer le déménagement pour notre nouvel
invité commençons
[Musique]
nos services sont toujours interdits pour moi qu'est
-ce que tu as besoin d'armes beaucoup d'armes tu penses que
tu peux prendre John mèche tu as un  mauvaise
surprise à venir
j'ai hâte de vous rencontrer
depuis longtemps
et jusqu'à présent vous n'avez pas déçu
nous pouvons continuer aussi longtemps que vous le souhaitez
mais cela ne se termine que dans un sens
[Musique]
tout cela pour quoi parce que  d'un chiot
n'était pas juste un chiot
vous